>>> LIFE AS WE KNOW RIGHT NOW
IMPOSSIBLE ON MARS.
BUT WHAT IF MARS WERE MORE LIKE
EARTH?
THE NOW FORMER CHIEF SCIENTIST
AT NASA, JAMES GREEN, SAYS IT
COULD BE POSSIBLE TO TERRAFORM
MARS, MAKE IT LIVABLE FOR
PEOPLE, WHEN CONJURES UP THE
SCENE FROM "THE MARTIAN" WHEN
MATT DAMON GETS STUCK ON MARS
AND HAS TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SURVIVE.
>> I GOT TO MAKE WATER AND GROW
FOOD ON A PLANET WHERE NOTHING
GROWS.
I AM THE GREATEST BOTANIST ON
THIS PLANET.
>> JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS IS
ASTROPHYSICIST WHO -- AN
ASTROPHYSICIST WHO WORKED WITH
GREEN.
WHAT JAMES GREEN IS TALKING
ABOUT HERE IS USING A MAGNETIC
SHIELD SO IT ISN'T SO DIFFICULT
FOR MATT DAMON/THE ASTRONAUT TO
GROW POTATOES ON MARS.
>> WHAT JIM IS DOING HERE IS
SOLVING A FEW OF THE PROBLEMS
ASSOCIATED WITH MARS.
SO ONE THING ABOUT PLANETARY
ATMOSPHERES, MARS OR THE EARTH,
THERE IS A BALANCE IN THE
ATMOSPHERE'S MASS.
THEY LOSE MASS, TYPICALLY DUE TO
EROSION FROM SUNLIGHT, BUT THE
ATMOSPHERE ALSO GAINS MASS.
ON EARTH, FROM VOLCANOS, BUT
BASICALLY COMES OUT OF THE
GROUND.
YOU HAVE A SYSTEM WHERE AIR IS
LEAVING AND AIR IS COMING IN.
SO WHAT JIM PROPOSES TO DO IS TO
CUT OFF THE SOURCE OF EROSION,
SO WHAT YOU CAN DO IS BETWEEN
MARS AND THE SUN, BETWEEN ANY
PLANET AND THE SUN, THERE IS A
LOW POINT IN THE GRAVITATIONAL
FIELD THAT YOU CAN ORBIT, THAT
IS DIRECTLY IN THE LINE BETWEEN
THEM.
SO IF YOU PUT A SPACECRAFT
THERE, AND YOU HAVE A BIG
MAGNETIC FIELD, THEN IT CAN
DEFLECT THAT SOLAR WIND AWAY
FROM THE PLANET AND YOU STOP THE
EROSION.
SO ONCE YOU STOP THE EROSION,
THE ATMOSPHERE BEGINS TO GAIN
MASS.
AND WHEN THE PRESSURE OF THE GAS
INCREASES, IT BECOMES HOTTER.
SO HE SOLVES THE PROBLEM OF MARS
BEING TOO COLD, AND HE ALSO
SOLVES THE PROBLEM OF GETTING
RID OF A LOT OF THE RADIATION
THAT REACHES THE SURFACE.
>> SO, PROFESSOR, I'M A DREAMER.
I'M A DREAMER.
I WANT TO BELIEVE EVERYTHING IS
POSSIBLE.
BUT WHAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING HERE
IS LIKE A GIANT SPACE SHIELD,
LIKE A SPACE VISOR, LIKE -- HOW
BIG DOES A CAR HAVE TO BE TO
HAVE A VISOR THAT WILL BLOCK THE
SUN FROM, YOU KNOW, SHINING ON
MARS?
>> WELL, THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS.
BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
IS THE ANGULAR SIZE, THAT MEANS
THAT AS YOU MOVE SOMETHING
FARTHER AWAY, THE ANGULAR SIZE
BECOMES SMALLER.
SO HERE THERE IS A VERY SPECIFIC
LOCATION WHERE THIS SPACECRAFT
HAS TO BE, BETWEEN MARS AND THE
SUN.
SO YOU HAVE TO DO THE
CALCULATION BASED ON THAT
LOCATION TO DETERMINE HOW MUCH
DEFLECTION YOU'RE ACTUALLY GOING
TO GET.
IT IS LIKE AN UMBRELLA FOR A
PLANET.
>> LIKE AN UMBRELLA FOR A --
THAT'S ONE BIG UMBRELLA.
YOU'RE -- JIM, AS YOU CALL HIM,
HE SAYS THAT HE'S PUTTING
TOGETHER A PAPER, RIGHT, PUTTING
TOGETHER A PAPER TO TALK ABOUT
HOW A MAGNETIC SHIELD WOULD
WORK.
HE SAID THERE IS SEVERAL
SCENARIOS FOR THAT.
HE ALSO SAID, THOUGH, IT IS NOT
GOING TO BE WELL RECEIVED.
WHY IS THAT?
>> WELL, BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, IN
SOME WAYS IT IS A ZERO SUM GAME,
IN SCIENCE, YOU HAVE COMMUNITIES
OF SCIENTISTS THAT GET BEHIND
PARTICULAR IDEAS THAT DETERMINE
WHERE THE FUNDING IS GOING TO GO
YEARS IN ADVANCE.
SO WE CALL THESE THINGS A
DECADAL SURVEY.
YOU COME UP WITH YOUR DECADAL
SURVEY, HERE IS WHAT WE SHOULD
DO FOR THE NEXT DECADE, HERE IS
OUR BIG PRIORITIES, AND, YOU
KNOW, THAT DETERMINES WHERE
MONEY GOES, THAT DETERMINES HOW
CAREERS ARE DEVELOPED BECAUSE
THERE ARE COMPETING IDEAS.
SO NOW HE'S GOING TO THROW HIS
IDEA INTO THAT COMPETITION.
AND IT DOESN'T REALLY FIT WELL
ANYWHERE, AND, YOU KNOW, IT IS A
REALLY NEW IDEA.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT HASN'T BEEN
DONE BEFORE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE DO
JUDGE ON IS TECHNICAL
FEASIBILITY.
SO IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT YOUR
NEW IDEA IS WHEN YOU'RE A
SCIENTIST.
TYPICALLY WHEN YOU PROPOSE IT,
YOUR FELLOW SCIENTISTS SAY, NO,
NOT GOING TO WORK, YOU SUCK.
>> YOUR UMBRELLA SUCKS IS WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY, I THINK.
>> JIM IS A PROVEN FACT, BUT,
YOU KNOW, THE DEFAULT SETTING
AMONG SCIENTISTS IS SKEPTICISM,
RIGHT?
AND SO YOU HAVE TO PROVE
YOURSELF TO EVERYONE.
EVEN WHEN YOU DO PROVE YOURSELF,
THEY STILL DON'T ADMIT YOU'RE
RIGHT.
SO, YOU KNOW, IT IS A TOUGH
SELL.
>> PROFESSOR, THIS IS
DELIGHTFUL.
I HAD NO IDEA THAT TERRAFORMING
WAS